it was today's technology we should be
able to hear another person's thoughts
it would be better if we had a human
maybe human enough for me three what
must have been a power outage last night
when Oliver makes an incredible
discovery make live for the total
package brains personality and good
looks things will never be the same
worse so old dogs understand
oh you must uh but you can't tell
anybody that's checkmate
I am your king pay this baby's baked for
you good luck at the fair now he must
make sure his new invention this kid a
special doesn't fall into the wrong
hands
oh my god it works you didn't I would do
anything to acquire this technology
[Music]
right now sit you sure you're not hungry
wait what no one said there be snacks
they've got adventure my human is in
trouble and I need your help
Oh didn't know you're having an awesome
party
down to a science they are going to save
Oliver
Gabriel bait man dude all mayor with
Megan Fox and Josh Duhamel
[Music]
oh we make a good team Henry
[Music]
think like a dog you smell as many butts
as I have you tend to pick up a few
things
[Music]
you